[Music]
I'm just saying I'm not gonna go I'm
just saying I have to poop after all
this [__] no you ate that dog food log
yeah
no that's like entirely figs
yeah it looks awesome I was expecting
meat and it just turned out oh dude it's
a fig loaf it's a fig log so I just have
to shout out this dude he's been around
for a minute I finally real like I
realized
who he is Bobby Holliday
not the artist but [__]
okay so this guy
on Tick Tock he goes by the Bobby
holiday experience but people have heard
of like you've seen him in memes before
but basically he just goes up to random
it's mostly random men and he pretends
to be like a gay lover of theirs in the
past
and it is
dude it's so [__] funny can we pulse
him up dude yeah let me link this one
dude with like their wives and [__] no
uh he'll just walk up to like two like
that one's like two guys working I
linked one in the talking points
that one with the million is crazy he
just walks with like these groups of
like this group of friends and just
doing it to all of them they're like yo
man let's get the [__] out of here like
they're like this one
bunches
it's me
yes
[Music]
those boys just crying laughing
what happened
anyway I didn't know you was with
somebody oh
my God
I can't really tell
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude a lot of times like he'll just like
crack he's like I'm just [__] with
you man but some of the other ones do
like he's he's like that dude infobren
where he'll just do crazy awkward [__]
dude this this one that one with 3.2
million views dude right up to a cop
yes I wrote that I was like oh my God
why you shaking your head like you don't
know yet
you're gorgeous okay
listen I'm going right right over there
you might get a call uh please ignore it
um my stimulus check
I found out he spun it all I'm just
gonna go there double tap on the chin
and I'm out of there so if they if they
call uh trying to take it quick and get
out that's all I appreciate it can I tap
you in the shoulder boom that's my gay
time uh it was a pleasure for you to
meet me today
you keep on doing you jaw drop thank you
have a good one
you okay yeah I said thank you but are
you high on the job
[Laughter]
DJ that's my gay top yeah that's my gate
um I'll talk to you later I love you yes
excuse me bro dude he's telling a cop
I'm gonna go right over there and knock
some dude out yeah ignore it so funny
hilarious he does a bunch for like he'll
go uh he'll go up to people working like
he did when he goes into a car
dealership and he's like uh he's like
hey everyone I'm just introducing myself
I'm gonna start I'm starting tomorrow
so
and like it's like NPC [__] like
everyone just they're like oh okay
it was just like dude he'll go hi my
name is Victoria
hi I'm Victoria I'm starting tomorrow so
how you doing I'm here for the job
interview my name Victoria
yes I'll be working with y'all probably
Monday how you doing good what you do
not much that's what they tell me oh you
work here though yeah oh I'm gonna be
your co-worker I can't wait good yeah oh
my god did they not notice any scars
yeah they don't really like he's just
holding his phone like I think yeah I
think he's just kind of just I see
okay bro this part
this is so funny
he's having a work meeting
I'm here to introduce myself my name
Victoria I'll be working with y'all and
I'm just introducing myself to everybody
how you doing good how are you looking
like Hulk Hogan cousin I like your beard
all right
oh
yeah this really is like a video yo yeah
oh what's going on man good I'm just uh
introducing myself my name Victoria I'm
gonna be your co-worker okay hey I see
you through the glass peekaboo
all right
I'm just stopping by and just saying hi
okay yeah I'll see you tomorrow
all right
tomorrow I'm wearing all pink and I'm
gonna have my belly button out so y'all
better get ready for me and you uh with
the fake Rolex I'm gonna bring you uh
lunch pink lemonade pink rice I'm going
fast on that why you say that right
huh
thank you you're the kindest person that
all of them giving me like the what's
the the hand that they use damn it I
like you me and you stop I mean how you
doing oh how you doing
good oh I see you used to have a Jerry
curl
hey stop
stop
Josh yo my name Bobby holiday I had to
stop in and do it
I love y'all man
dude is he not actually gay like is he
does he not actually no no I think I
think he is okay but he just like yeah
he'll just dude there's another one
there's a whole rabbit hole we don't
have to go through anymore yeah we just
walks into a construction worker like on
site the dude's like holding a ruler
he's like you're gonna need a bigger one
than that
it's this dude yeah
you're gonna need a bigger one than that
cow
I said you're gonna need a bigger one
than that trust me but wait
he's like huh that's all from climax
yeah but I'm working right now my man
don't put that ruling near me that was a
close one what's your name
um delicious
yeah you remember exactly wait a minute
hold on I don't want to talk no more
like me delicious
yeah nice
looking for Castle here with me cookie
foot cancer is here with me
where you from I'm from North Philly
yeah I am from Philly oh Coco Puffs got
the wrong person
here
[Laughter]
[Music]
the stuff that you are loved how much oh
no my man
hey yeah delicious caught up for his
supervisor
[Laughter]
it's always ends up being like really
wholesome which I think is like makes it
even funnier yeah I agree yeah if they
were actually pissed I'd be like ah [__]
no there's some that some dudes get like
angry I need to get upset and they like
step to him and he'll be like why are
you acting like that it's so funny bro